MAX SALTONSTALL: Welcome to
"BeyondCorp in a Bottle,"
where we explore
journeys into the world
of context-aware access
and zero-trust networks.
Perimeter security definitely
was a good idea a while back.
When IT systems just began to
get connected to the internet,
some sort of barrier had
to protect your systems
on the inside from the
baddies on the outside.
Now this model is broken.
Walls don't work.
And to change, you're going
to need more and new hardware
or software.
You need to change how you
think about access and security.
While it feels secure, the
perimeter model functions
more like an egg--
hard shell on the outside,
soft, gooey center inside.
That's because once
people get past your wall,
they have full access to all
the internal systems you're
trying to protect.
Looks delicious to an attacker.
Add to that your workforce,
heading outside your perimeter
to meetings,
conferences, and clients,
using mobile devices
along the way, which
aren't friendly with
your VPN software.
You also want to secure access
for contractors and vendors.
But they shouldn't
be able to see
all of your internal
systems and data.
So you need a way to give
them a limited view--
a small slice of access.
As your company
keeps innovating,
you're probably using more
and more cloud services.
The tools have
left the perimeter.
Now they're running as a service
on one cloud or another--
harder and harder for a wall
to keep them all safe inside.
And your employees
face constantly
evolving cyber threats looking
to get inside your perimeter
through malware, phishing,
hardware exploits, and more.
And it just takes
one Trojan horse
to bring that adversary
inside your castle.
It's time to change
your security posture.
Enforce strong
multi-factor authentication
with phishing-resistant
keys, like these.
Get your employee devices
under active management,
and regularly
monitor their health.
Control access to systems
based on identity and device
data, rather than
location or network.
You can do this today.
And I'm here to help.
To get more detail on
the right next steps,
read more of my
post linked below.
Thanks for watching,
and subscribe
to get more videos on
context-aware access.
When it comes to protecting your
company, keep your data yours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]